on home turf for what could be the most
consequential prosecution in U.S history
America's 45th president but the first
to face something like this
what a slow drive for the president as
he approaches his golf club but I have
to say there are more media here than
there are supporters he will surely be
hoping that the base swells a bit more
than this
[Music]
[Applause]
the support that was here conservative
from across the Spectrum was angry
[Music]
determined and representing many more
across the country he's you know being
picked on really all the other
presidents have done the same thing he's
doing I think the allegations against
Joe Biden and his family are
significantly more serious than the ones
against Donald Trump it breaks my heart
to think that we are on a way to
becoming a Banana Republic here outside
the Miami Courthouse the stage is being
set to record this spectacle the most
high profile person ever to face
criminal charges under the Espionage Act
when the indictment was unsealed Donald
Trump was on his golf course spotted by
Sky News through the weekend we've
followed him to rallies across the
country
in Columbus Georgia the setting was an
old factory which once made guns for the
Civil War
in places like this not the courtroom
where he is presenting his defense to
crowds of riled supporters
and with his political allies too on
Niche networks broadcasting to just one
side this is Carrie Lake one time
Arizona governor hopeful she lost claims
she was robbed and is now Trump's
cheerleader I think
[Applause]
we saw what happened when we ignored a
corrupt election and allowed someone
like Joe Biden to get into the White
House and Lead our country into
destruction you can you can look down
the camera and say that but you know
that's not true you know that the
election was not still I wouldn't expect
you coming from Australia to know one
dance you're from the UK oh you're from
the UK I was told you're from Australia
Carrie Lake could conceivably be Donald
Trump's running mate for vice president
expect you to understand what's
happening in our country because I can
see you've come at this from a left
agenda which is very typical of the fake
news
the seriousness of the charges are not
the focus here because they believe this
is a hit job by Biden to remove his
political rival they point to Joe
Biden's own Scandal and the documents
found at his home his son Hunter and
that laptop both under investigation and
to the Hillary Clinton scandal the
difference though between those and
Trump is quantity and the allegations
that Trump intended to take the
documents and try to hide them Mark
Stone Sky News in Miami